حسنًا ، منذ متى يا
رفاق وكيف تطورت منذ
البداية ، لذلك بدأنا lamda في عام 2013
بدأ كمشروع عضوي من المنزل
أدركنا أنه لا يوجد الكثير
في اللغة العربية للأطفال لذلك قلنا لماذا لا
نقوم بإنشاء محتوى رائع يكون ممتعًا
ولكن في نفس الوقت يكون تعليميًا كان
التسويق الخاص بك في الغالب من خلال
شركاء التوزيع في البداية ،
نعم لأن التسويق قد يكون مكلفًا ،
أردنا اختبار
أشخاص مختلفين من جماهير مختلفة كيف يتفاعل الناس
مع الرسائل التي بدأنا باستثمارها  في
قنواتنا التسويقية الخاصة بنا
على أساس الأداء ، قم بإنشاء
فريق تسويق ومحرك تسويق يعمل على توجيه
الأشخاص باستمرار ويأخذهم من
خلال الخطوات الصحيحة حتى
تحصل على التحويل الصحيح ، من المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لك تحديد
المستخدم الفعلي مقابل عميلك  كانت
إحدى أكبر الدروس المستفادة هي أن
المستخدم هو الطفل الفعلي والعميل
هو الوالد ، لذلك تحدثنا مع الأطفال عبر
المرح بواسطة mu  كذا عن طريق الفنون من خلال الألعاب
وتحدثنا مع أولياء الأمور على
قنوات مختلفة كيف ترى
منافسيك أو كيف ترى ما
يفعلونه وكيف يؤثر على ما تفعله نحن في
الواقع ننظر إلى الكثير من هذه
المبادرات بطريقة إيجابية  من خلال
الوصول إليهم وهناك العديد من
الزوايا المتعلقة بهذه المساحة بحيث إذا كانت
كل شركة متخصصة في زاوية واحدة
أو تتلاءم معًا كشركات متعددة
في هذا المجال ، فيمكننا أن نكمل بعضنا
البعض لتقديم
رؤية أكبر تخدم أطفال المنطقة
النصيحة التي أود أن أعطيها لأي
شخص يبدأ
مبادرة أو شركة ناشئة هي اختيار
شركائك بحكمة شديدة ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
علاقات تحتاج إلى شخص
يفتح لك أربعة أبواب لأنك تحتاج إلى شخص
أكثر أهمية لتؤمن بقوة
الإيمان.  مهم في حياة الشركات الناشئة ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى أشخاص
من حولك يؤمنون بك ويدعمونك
فيها ، ويكون جيدًا وأيضًا السيئ إلى أي مدى
كنت واضحًا في حافلة تحقيق الدخل ،
فالأمر كله يتعلق بـ testi  لقد كنا
نختبر الكثير من الأشياء تعمل بعض
الأشياء لا تعمل ، نرى بسرعة
العلامات وإما أن
نركز على ما نقوم به أو نثابر عليه ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك لقد استمتعت
بالرحلة كثيرًا